estudiamos el mercado del refresco un
poco así que vamos a dibujar nuestros
ejes tradicionales aquí tenemos el
precio y este es el eje de la cantidad y
ya hemos visto nuestras curvas clásicas
de oferta y demanda así que esta es la
curva de oferta con pendiente creciente
a un precio pequeño no muchas personas
quieren producir refrescos y mientras
aumenta el precio más personas quieren
producirlos y también podemos verla como
la curva del costo marginal donde la
primera unidad es muy fácil de producir
y después es más caro o costoso producir
ya que tienes que contratar y capacitar
a más personas y conseguir un inmueble
para tus fábricas
etcétera así que puedes ver esta como tu
curva de costo marginal y por el lado de
la demanda tenemos nuestra clásica curva
con pendiente decreciente
a un precio alto no muchas personas
quieren comprar refresco y mientras que
el precio baja más personas querrán
consumir refresco
así que esta es nuestra curva de la
demanda que podemos verla como la curva
del beneficio marginal con la primera
unidad de refresco alguien va a
conseguir un beneficio alto por ello ya
que alguien tendrá que pagar un precio
alto y por cada unidad adicional las
personas obtendrán un beneficio menor
porque las personas estarán dispuestas a
pagar un precio menor por lo que nos da
está pendiente decreciente así que
podemos verlo como la curva de beneficio
marginal todo esto es un repaso
tendremos nuestra cantidad de equilibrio
que el mercado produciría y tenemos
nuestro precio de equilibrio pero ahora
vamos a presentar una idea nueva ya que
todo lo que hemos hablado el beneficio y
el costo marginal todo esto es el
beneficio marginal privado y el costo
marginal privado es decir no tenemos en
cuenta los beneficios ni los costos de
la sociedad así que déjenme reetiquetar
todo esto un poco en lugar de decir
beneficio marginal voy a llamar a esto
como beneficio marginal privado y el
lugar del costo marginal que nombraremos
costo marginal privado y este es el
precio de equilibrio que obtendremos si
sólo tenemos en cuenta los costos y los
beneficios privados y esta es la
cantidad de equilibrio que obtendremos
si sólo tenemos en cuenta los costos y
los beneficios privados así que ya sé lo
que estás pensando esto me parece
agradable sal pero qué pasa si tenemos
en cuenta los costos y los beneficios
sociales
bueno para algo como el refresco puedes
tener algunos costos sociales negativos
y cuando tienes costos sociales se dice
que tienes externalidades negativas
cuando estás pensando en este caso en el
refresco puede ser que las latas
contaminen y la sociedad deba limpiarlas
puede ser que toda el azúcar o el jarabe
de maíz dentro de la sangre de las
personas les produzca diabetes o que se
les caigan los dientes y la sociedad
tendrá que pagar por ello
de alguna forma así que otra forma de
pensar esto mismo es que podemos agregar
estas externalidades negativas al costo
marginal privado y obtener una curva del
costo marginal social así que déjame
hacerlo si agregamos las externalidades
negativas obtendremos una curva del
costo marginal social déjame escribirlo
una curva del costo marginal social
y digamos que para el refresco el
beneficio privado solo por simplicidad
es igual al beneficio marginal social
así que esta curva es la misma que la
curva del beneficio marginal social
ahora si pensamos desde la perspectiva
social cuál es el precio y la cantidad
óptima bueno tendremos que pensar en
donde el costo marginal social es igual
al beneficio marginal social ya que
querrá seguir produciendo siempre que el
beneficio social sea mayor que el costo
social pero cuando el costo social es
mayor que el beneficio social no tenemos
algo positivo eso creará una ganancia
negativa o un daño en la sociedad así
que es racional producir hasta esta
cantidad es decir esta cantidad de aquí
que es la cantidad óptima desde el punto
de vista social y este será el precio
óptimo desde el punto de vista social
pero si sólo dejas que los mercados
privados sean como son entonces qué
pasará bueno en ese caso se producirá
demasiado desde el punto de vista social
y si lo piensas desde el punto de vista
social
es lo que es óptimo pero como produces
toda esta cantidad de más donde el costo
marginal social es mayor que el
beneficio marginal social entonces todo
esto es lo que se va a llevar del
beneficio social es decir del excedente
total para la sociedad así que esto va a
crear una pérdida de eficiencia ya que
estas dos cantidades son distintas
también podemos pensar en un escenario
con externalidades positivas pensemos en
el mercado de aparatos de ejercicio y
podemos dibujar ejes similares y curvas
similares así que tenemos aquí la
cantidad aquí el precio tenemos nuestra
curva de beneficio marginal privado que
podemos llamar la curva de demanda y
también tenemos nuestra curva del costo
marginal privado justo así y vamos a
decir que este mercado produce si sólo
pensamos en los costos y beneficios
privados
la cantidad de equilibrio desde el punto
de vista privado y este precio de
equilibrio pero esta vez digamos que
tenemos una externalidad positiva qué
significa
bueno que entre más aparatos de
ejercicio existan allí más ejercitan las
personas y eso las hará más felices eso
disminuye los costos del cuidado de su
salud y por lo tanto queremos sumar ese
beneficio adicional es decir esa
externalidad positiva a la curva del
beneficio marginal privado para obtener
la curva de la ganancia marginal social
así que vamos a hacerlo así que vamos a
sumar esto y vamos a obtener la curva de
beneficio marginal social y digamos que
la curva del costo marginal privado es
la misma que la curva del costo marginal
social
y si piensas que es lo óptimo para la
sociedad bueno ellos querrán que se
produzca más y más y más aparatos de
ejercicio siempre que el beneficio
marginal social sea mayor que el costo
marginal social pero cuando el costo
marginal social es mayor que la ganancia
marginal social no tiene lógica que se
cree un valor negativo así que lo óptimo
para la sociedad es producir hasta esta
cantidad así que esta es la cantidad
óptima para la sociedad y este es el
precio óptimo para la sociedad pero si
solo tenemos los costos y beneficios
privados que decidan el precio y la
cantidad de equilibrio sólo seremos
capaces de producir hasta aquí pero
desde el punto de vista social estamos
perdiendo toda esta cantidad donde el
beneficio marginal social es mayor que
el costo marginal social y por lo tanto
tenemos esta pérdida de eficiencia
así que en resumen cuando se tienen en
cuenta externalidades negativas o
externalidades positivas descubres una
pérdida de eficiencia para la sociedad
así que una pregunta interesante es
pensar en cómo podría la sociedad
rectificar todo esto hay varias formas
de al menos empezar a aproximarse